et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
patrick kanner bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous est sénateur du nord
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représenté par
creissels leur temps ne compte pas des
pages pour christelle bonjour oriane
montchamp patrick hannais bonjour
l'homme et on va parler évidemment de 7
après législatives à elisabeth bande a
présenté sa démission hier emmanuel
macron l'a refusé afin que le
gouvernement reste à sa tâche c'est ce
qu'il a dit est ce qu elle a eu raison
en tout cas il aurait pu l'accepter la
renommée ce qui était quand même
beaucoup plus gênant pour la suite donc
en la refusant elle reste sur le fil
manifestement
essais dans les jours qui viennent que
nous pourrons voir si madame bande
encore un avenir elle n'a pas que non
vous n'avez pas sa démission ce matin
contrairement à certains membres de leur
pays écoutez voilà il ya eu un petit
mammouth ou cette affaire je pense que
l'agenda
international du président de la
république l'empêchent de faire des
consultations au fond même si
aujourd'hui il est encore en négociation
en tout cas en discussions avec les
chefs de partis pour imaginer je ne sais
pas quel gouvernement on y reviendra
sûrement et et donc il veut se donner du
temps et donc s'il avait accepté les
démissions et bien ils étaient coincés
la renommée c'était gênant donc voilà il
l'a refusé pour je pense gagner du temps
peut-être que man band sauvera sa tête
mais je n'en suis pas certain et je vous
parle si elle ne se sauve pas leur
profil plutôt plutôt à gauche les habite
berne si elle ne sauvait pas sa tête est
ce que vous craignez à nouveau un
premier ministre de droite comme ça a
été le cas durant le précédent
quinquennat écouter permettez moi quand
même de vous dire que madame borne est à
gauche quand elle travaillait pour des
patrons de gauche et l'état droite quand
elle travaille pour les partis de droite
s'adaptent elles s'adaptent elles
s'adaptent donc voulait dire qu'elle n'a
pas une certaine influence sur la ligne
elle peut elle peut avoir des
convictions profondes ça je n'en doute
pas mais c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
loyal et ce qu'on demande d'ailleurs un
premier ministre et donc quand on
travaille pour un président qui a
présenté un programme de droite au pays
eh bien on est de droite quel que soit
le profil du premier ministre emmanuel
macron appliquera la politique il a
dessiné un sel vous êtes en train de
dire le jupitérien est
fragilisé et on a bien vu au travers de
la dispersion du front républicain du
délitement deux fois plus qu'un qu'on a
créé un autre français le front anti
macro et donc il en train de subir cela
d' en pleine figure manifestement il est
affaibli mais sur les fondamentaux il
reste il reste le même et je crois
d'ailleurs que dans ce cadre puisqu'on
dit le président va s'exprimer on ne
sait pas quel
non seulement je pense qu'ils veulent
faire mais puisqu'on retrouve du groupe
armé lente parlementarisme et bien moi
je le dis à votre micro aujourd'hui et
j'ai consulté il y à quelques instants
ma collègue valérie rabault présidente
du groupe socialiste donc à l'assemblée
jusqu'au moment où il y aura une
nouvelle élection au sein de ce groupe
je les consulter et nous pensons qu'il
serait extrêmement utile que le
président de la république s'exprime
devant les instances de la nation à
savoir le congrès dont je veux dire
votre micro
aujourd'hui
le président de république pour fixer sa
ligne fixé le cap pour la nation ont
fixé le cap pour le pays
expliquer comment il voit les choses
après cet échec politique qui s'est
traduit dimanche soir dernier est bien
la meilleure manière de parler au pays
c'est d'abord de par les représentants
de la nation et donc le congrès depuis
2008 est une opportunité pour lui le
congrès à versailles et je pense que ça
devrait se limiter à cela et notamment
avant la déclaration de politique
générale du premier ministre est
rapidement mais c'est la déclaration +10
générale est prévue le 5 juillet
pour l'instant pour l'instant ça sert à
quoi tu sais que tu es aujourd'hui mais
ça permet notamment aux différentes
sensibilités politiques existent au
parlement de pouvoir dire au président
de la république je comment nous voyons
plutôt que de faire des discussions est
ce qu'il est c'est ce que tout le monde
est en train de faire aujourd'hui il
reçoit tout les composants aimé mais de
manière secrète quasiment pas je suis
dire moi je n'assiste pas à ce qui se
passe dans la transparence je veux de la
clarté et je veux que le pays soit
témoin des engagements du président de
la république après cet événement majeur
de dimanche dernier aux élections
législatives je veux aussi que le sénat
ne peut pas être entre guillemets la
roue de secours ni des uns ni les autres
lequel allait rencontrer les chefs de
partis à l'assemblée vous demande à être
nous sommes pas les supplétifs de qui
que ce soit et donc nous sommes la
deuxième chambre du parlement français
et si madame borgne a envie de savoir ce
que ressentent ce que ressent le pays
même si nous n'avons pas l'exhaustivité
de ce ressentiment je pense que
interroger les présidents de groupe tout
cas moi je suis disponible car elle est
trop chère
l'un est mise à l'écart c'est moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour la semaine
nationale bien évidemment mais à un
moment donné il faut qu'on redevienne un
élément dans la boucle de la démocratie
et cette boucle elle comporte le sénat
donc deux propositions concrètes je suis
prêt à être reçus par madame bornes et
je demande au président de la république
avec ma collègue valérie rabault de
convoquer le congrès pour qu'il
s'explique devant les représentants de
la nation et que nous puissions lui
feront pas aussi mais collectivement pas
par petit bout pas par entre guillemets
comme dans une pièce célèbre les horace
et les curiaces qui viennent là un peu à
canossa devant le président de la
république donc s'il l'aimait plus
jupitérien aujourd'hui eh bien il doit
pouvoir sans problème venir devant les
représentants du pays philippe dire
qu'il fallait rentrer dans une logique
de grande coalition y compris avec les
socialistes est-ce qu'il a raison
sa priorité c'est pas les socialistes où
vous l'avez entend lui aussi
oui il a dit les socialistes
mais là aussi un peu comme des
supplétifs mais je pense que dans sa
tête la logique considérant son parcours
personnel c'est faisant une grande
coalition
donc vers la droite finalement ce serait
la conclusion logique de la campagne
menée par où la petite campagne menée
par monsieur macro et les siens on a
bien vu quand même que la jambe gauche
commençait à devenir extrêmement
nécrosés et que c'est vraiment la jambe
droit qui était la plus forte donc il
est dans sa danse aux logiques je
préfère nettement la notion de coalition
à droite en l'occurrence que celle
d'union nationale oui je vais opposer la
question françois bayrou lui dit il faut
aller chercher l'union nationale la plus
large possible donc là il inclut bien
aussi la gauche je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire l'union nationale l'union
nationale
par exemple 100 et les filles et 100
et
s'en aller ça veut dire qu'il ya un
tiers du
du parlement à l'assemblée nationale en
tout cas qui disparaît bon c'est assez
curieux puis l'hymne national savez
nationale c'est qu'il n'y a personne
d'écarter sinon ça n'est qu'une
coalition donc
ali sion je trouve que ce serait plus
logique si le prix d'un public veut une
majorité qui le qu'il aille chercher les
siens et donc essien c'est plutôt à
droite mais j'ai bien compris il
voit pas ce que nous ferions au regard
du programme et puis une communion
nationale c'est d'abord bâtir un
programme de gouvernement qui permettent
à chacun de s'y retrouver et ça se fait
souvent dans le cadre de ces accords
dans des régimes parlementaires
on peut on dire on parle souvent de
l'allemagne en ce moment en longtemps
que le spd donc les sociaux démocrates
ont fait une alliance avec les libéraux
oui mais dans un régime parlementaire il
n'ya pas de président élu le président a
été élu et il est aujourd'hui affaiblie
par le vote de dimanche dernier encore
une fois dans une logique de front anti
macron ça montre quoi ça montre
simplement qu'il est dans la panique
générale et qu'ils essayent par tous les
biais de trouver une solution qui lui
permette de rester à son poste
au gouvernement vous devez refuser on
peut y avoir deux socialistes au
gouvernement pour vous mais nous ne
sommes pas la croix-rouge permettait
autrefois si j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour la croix rouge
voilà il ya une ambulance qui est mal en
point
la république en marche la reine est
passé à l'arrêt la république en pane e
où
il faut regarder les choses on n'est pas
là pour être encore une fois les
sauveteurs d'un président qui a été
sanctionné pour sa verticalité pour son
incapacité à gérer les corps
intermédiaires pour mépriser de fait le
parlement est maintenant le roi est nu
le roi est nu le l'illusion macro de
2017 est devenu un défaut il a été élu
par défaut en 2022 donc
que les choses soient claires qu'ils se
débrouillent excusez moi l'expression
qu'ils se débrouillent d'abord avec les
siens que ces supports est très clair
que joël giraud qui est pressenti pour
être peut-être le futur président de
l'assemblée nationale disais hier il va
nous falloir aller chercher des
majorités texte par tex à ces logis est
ce que le parti socialiste pourrait
soutenir certains tel qu'on l'a fait
celui qui arrive sur le pouvoir d'achat
par exemple est ce que vous pourriez
être les siens vont arrêter notre
position on a toujours été dans une
logique d'opposition
propositions avec des amendements sig
par le fait de cette majorité relative
on regarde maintenant les amendements de
l'opposition avec un peu plus de
bienveillance
vous savez moi j'ai vu au sénat on a été
balayée pour les amendements par la
droite bien souvent est quasiment
systématiquement par le gouvernement ce
qui nous a amenés à voter contre le
texte mais si certains nos amendements
et on l'a toujours dit dans lesdites
dans les discussions générales qui
précède les débats parlementaires si ça
donne aux amendements qui nous semblent
importants sont respectées on peut être
amené sinon a voté pour au moins à
s'abstenir ce qui permet aux textes de
prospérer donc on n'a jamais ses
pouvoirs d'achat concrètement bien
souvenir c'était bien sûr si si on fait
des propositions par exemple
si la prime macron
quand on annonce triplé qui pour moi la
traduction du travail au noir
institutionnalisée je le répète souvent
une prime non fiscalisée non chargé
c'est une séduit travail au noir qui
n'est plus à anonymiser je le reconnais
mais c'est quand même du travail au noir
est donc cette crise macro moi je ne
peux pas je veux une hausse réelle du
pouvoir d'achat au travers du salaire
donc si nous sommes entendus sur des
choses comme ça si nous sommes entendus
sur le fait que pour augmenter les
moyens en faveur des du pouvoir d'achat
et bien on taxe un peu plus les plus
riches de ce pays et c'est sur yon prêts
à voter sur la crise de la dette du coc
vide quand il a fallu dégager des
milliards d'euros des dizaines de
milliards d'euros eh bien le groupe sis
à voter ces mesures parce qu'elle nous
semblaient bonnes pour le pays donc nous
ne serons pas dans l'opposition et
l'obstruction systématique jean luc
mélenchon appelle les habitants à se
soumettre à un vote de confiance à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que voit si
vous dites oui là elle pas passer par an
c'est la logique des institutions ce
n'est pas dans les textes mais s'il ya
une déclaration de politique générale il
faut qu'elles soient jugés et le
meilleur vote c'est l'engagement de
responsabilité du double non ce n'est
pas obligatoire encore une fois c'est à
la disposition et c'est pour cela que
pour l'instant on n'en sait rien
aujourd'hui
ces discussions devraient permettre à
madame bornes au travers de monsieur
macron de savoir si oui ou non elle
aurait une majorité relative mais une
majorité quand même à l'assemblée le 5
juillet vous êtes favorable une motion
de censure
la moindre censure c'est un droit qui
est donné l'opposition et et
heureusement et qui notamment contre
balance par exemple les articles qu'ils
valent et au gouvernement de passer en
force comme le 49 alinéa 3 donc je suis
favorable au principe de la motion de
censure
le 5 juillet mais je n'en suis je ne
serais favorable que à la suite de la
déclaration de politique générale pas en
préalable
de l efi 10 moucheron censure mais avant
même de savoir ce que va dire me le
borgne mais je vais faire et c'est un
pas important dans le parisien il disait
pas non
pardon je ne suis pas défavorable aux
chaussures commune à la gauche était
chaque copains d'abord et
essentiellement d'ailleurs la semaine
nationale mais à condition d'abord qu'on
écoute ce que va dire madame bornes
c'est après cette ce débat qu'on pourra
déposer une motion de censure l'a
déposée par principe en amont bon voilà
c'est je pense que ce n'est pas dans
l'esprit avec des institutions dernière
question sur le gouvernement vous disiez
tout à l'heure elisabeth borne est sur
le fil du rasoir elle sera peut-être pas
le premier ministre encore dans un an -
est ce que vous appelez un remaniement
rapide
catherine de roche qui était sur ce
plateau juste avant vous disais on peut
pas rester par exemple sans ministre de
la santé très longtemps il ya une
urgence est ce que vous appelez en
remaniant rapide pour pourvoir les
postes vacants ma collègue de roche a
raison
parce que la situation sanitaire du pays
et notamment sur les urgences est
catastrophique
mais qu'est ce que j'ai vu hier j'ai vu
une réunion du conseil des ministres
sous l'autorité de madame bornes
à matignon ou des ministres battus voilà
choisi coucou à la presse contrairement
à tout ce qui est dans les principes
finalement de nos institutions moi je le
regrette quoi donc on est vraiment dans
l'antre 2 c'est pas dans le même temps
c'est dans l'antre de aujourd'hui c'est
une situation qui n'est pas saine pour
le bon fonctionnement de nos
institutions donc il faut vite en sortir
et notamment sur la santé il faut que
les personnels de santé il faut que les
français tout simplement sache qui sera
leur milice la semaine pour remanier un
gouvernement là c'est plus possible
c'est trop long c'est beaucoup trop long
notamment sur cette question prioritaire
madame bourguignon doit démissionner et
on doit la remplacer dans l'est dans les
meilleurs délais mais voilà voilà la
situation dans laquelle on est c'est une
situation inédite et inquiétante
finalement pour l'image de la france
même si je pense que ce pays reste
gouvernable majorité relative ce n'est
pas une défaite c'est une majorité
relative le président de la république a
connu un échec mais il peut s'en sortir
finalement qu'il soit plus clair dans
ses positions et qu'il aille chercher à
droite finalement ce qu'il est au bout
du bout sur la situation à gauche les
socialistes n'ont pas plus de députés
que dans la précédente législature est
ce que pour vous c'est l'échec de la
stratégie de la nuit non non parce que
je suis incapable de vous dire que si on
était parti tout seul on aurait une
autre groupe donc voilà nous avons un
groupe j'en suis content il faut encore
voir dans quelles conditions il va se
constituer bien évidemment puisqu'il ya
des voix là j'entends dire que les
ignorants group est un groupe unique de
la nuque comme l'a proposé jean luc
mélenchon d'ailleurs il est revenu sur
cette proposition donc ça veut dire
qu'il ya parlé trop vite 1
donc il a parlé trop vite
sur le principe mais le leader à
l'internaute pourquoi pas parce que ça
permet d'avoir une coordination une
cohérence dans les prises de position de
la gauche qui a été élu sur la même
bannière les faisait sur les postes clés
à l'assemblée aussi peut-être oui mais
mais dans toutes les hypothèses avant de
ne pas laisser la commission des
finances à l'assemblée nationale pour
vous elle doit aller au rassemblement
national
c'est un vrai sujet c'est un vrai sujet
la première force politique c'est la
nuque
mais ce n'est pas le premier groupe et
donc on verra comment le président de la
semaine nationale
la majorité relative considère ce
problème le la poutre temps encore en
train de travailler comme dirait
rassemblement national
je serais très inquiet de voir un arn
afn arn peu importe patron de cette
importante institution c'est ce que dit
jean luc mélenchon qui produit la
commission des temps qu'il faut
peut-être trouver les voies et moyens
pour trouver un bon accord sur le
principe de l'effet l'opposition
présider cette commission tout en
évitant
[Musique]
valérie rabault par exemple la poutre
est en train de travailler en tant que
c'est pas non je je
je connais donc je connais la compétence
pouvait devenir président des
commissions finances je crois que ce
serait une bonne chose pour l'opposition
et pour le pays voilà je vous dis très
très ce plan mais je ne suis pas député
ça ne vous aura pas échappé et cela
n'eut pas encore un avenir je cite
gérard larcher ce matin dans parisien il
dit le succès de la nuque est relatif
car elle existe déjà plus est un
stratège électoral payante mais vide de
sens politiquement
chercher devrait d'abord regarder ce qui
se passe chez lui avant d'aller voir ce
qui se passe chez les autres c'est une
construction nouvelle extrêmement
récente c'est au pied du mur qu'on verra
le masson selon la formule consacrée
il faut laisser les gens travailler
ensemble simplement il faut que ça se
fasse dans le respect des uns des autres
la proposition de monsieur mélenchon sur
le groupe unique n'était pas tout à fait
respectueuse des verts des socialistes
ou des communistes et pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il en est revenu donc si ça
fonctionne dans le respect dans
l'autonomie de chacun ce qui est prévu
d'ailleurs dans l'accord c'est ce qui
est prévu dans l'accord et pas autre
chose nous ne sommes pas dans une
logique de fusion absorption à nous de
créer les conditions pour que cela
apparaisse comme un espoir retrouvé pour
les français qui veulent le
rassemblement de la gauche mais
l'ensemble de la gauche ce n'est pas
l'effacement des un profit des autres et
j'ai juste un mot puisque les prochaines
élections ce sont les sénatoriales
est-ce que vous souhaitez qu'il y ait
des candidats de la nuque au sénat
taurian ou là vous dites non il faut des
candidats socialistes parce que ce que
j'ai dit ben c'est un dans un drain
grand de madère
ce qu'on appelle le point de quitter
donc un écho qui toujours un raccourci
ce que je dis simplement c'est que l efi
à pratiquer la règle à calcul pour nous
dit ah ben voilà combien vous aurez à
peu près de députés les uns et les
autres et et nous on prend la part du
lion 330 députés candidats sur
l'ensemble des circonscriptions je dis
simplement que les filles aujourd'hui à
très peu de grands électeurs que ce
n'est pas la même élection
et que bien évidemment il faudra tenir
compte des rapports de force existant
donc oui à des candidats de la nuque à
condition qu'elle soit majeure état mais
la nuque a été créé pour l'assemblée
nationale nous verrons bien si le
prospère globalement comme un accord
politique nationale y compris sur le
fond et pas uniquement sur un accord
électoral ce que je sais c'est que
l'élection sénatoriale a lieu dans plus
d'un an maintenant fin septembre 2023
que de l'eau coulera sous les ponts
d'ici là et on verra bien quels seront
les rapports de force et quelles seront
les conditions de la construction de la
gauche simplement ce que je sais c'est
que eh bien il y a aujourd'hui trois
groupes au sénat de gauche et que ces
trois présidents de groupe dont je suis
avec eux me gontard et madame à ceux ci
travaillent déjà ensemble donc l'union
de la gauche au sénat elle existe elle
passe pas par un intergroupe mais nous
travaillons déjà ensemble si elle est
fille veut avoir des sénateurs nous le
verrons bien je tiens quand même à
rappeler que le programme de l efi
d'avenir en commun c'est la suppression
du sénat qui est proposée au profit
d'une chambre
d'interpellations populaire donc jusqu'à
présent il n'y avait pas de candidat
elle est fille en tout cas il n'est pas
question pour moi de sacrifier pour être
clair des places de socialistes sortants
au profit d'une alliance qui ne
reposerait pas sur une véritable
présence territoriale
olivier faure a été réélu dimanche
de façon assez confortable est ce que il
peut désormais se maintenir à la tête du
ps est ce que vous y êtes favorable mais
le congrès va avoir lieu en octobre vous
a pas échappé qu'il y avait eu voilà
d'autres sensibilités qui s'étaient
exprimés qui certes n'ont pas
globalement réussie sur le plan
électoral il faut il faut le dire il y
avait 70 dans il ya peut-être trois ou
quatre qui ont été élues 4 ou 5 vous
avez une réconciliation
savez je suis un fils spirituel de
pierre mauroy et puis à braver un mot
permanent la bouche c'est le
rassemblement il faut que la gauche se
rassemble et il faut en particulier que
la famille socialiste se se rassemblent
les récents tirs à la tête si on verra
bien s'il est candidat à sa succession
bien évidemment il y a une autre
sensibilité qui s'est exprimé depuis le
dernier congrès de villeurbanne au sein
du parti socialiste portés par hélène
geoffroy il a eu des prises de position
de carole delga de françois hollande de
stéphane le foll est ce que nous devons
nous parler la réponse est oui et je
pense que l'objectif aujourd'hui n'est
pas d'être dans la lutte des places mais
dans la reconstruction dans la
refondation idéologique du parti
socialiste parce que finalement nous
sommes contents d'avoir un groupe mais
j'ai quand même un petit groupe disons
le clairement et que nous sommes
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus la force
centrale de la gauche et je considère
que monsieur mélenchon qui a été
candidat trois fois à la présence de
république kate est candidat à matignon
n'a pas réussi donc je rappelle
qu'historiquement c'est toujours le
parti socialiste qui a mené la gauche au
pouvoir retrouvons cette place centrale
au ministre à l'ancien musée sport que
vous n'êtes pas très claires puisque le
sénat travaille sur la lumière faire la
lumière sur le fiasco de l'organisation
des finales de la ligue des champions
vous aviez demandé vous l'audition des
supporters de liverpool et du real l ue
hier elle est assez accablant longtemps
c'est ce qui s'est passé ce soir là et
sur les explications données par gérald
darmanin ce que gérald darmanin peut se
maintenir en poste
vous avez entendu les supporters anglais
espagnols qui étaient là hier des gens
très calme très posé et cetera ils ont
touché le même mot monsieur darmanin
aurait dû démissionner après un tel
fiasco et même s'il est probable
en dans une culture anglo saxonne il
aurait démissionné ce n'est pas le cas
en france ce qui est certain c'est que
il était très sûr de lui trop sûr de lui
à l'audition au sénat ce que nous avons
entendu hier était accablant la
situation était apocalyptique
ce 28 mai dernier au stade de france et
didier lallement préfet de police a dit
clairement d'ailleurs ça a été volée sur
une vidéo qu'il était là pour protéger
le ministre il a protégé le ministre est
pas la première fois d'ailleurs qu'il
protège le ministre mais abandonné il
faut rendre des comptes je pense que
monsieur darmana devrait être au moins
rester roger devant la commission les
commissions buffet la faune pour être
très clair je l' ai proposé hier un
fonctionnel buffet qui étaient présents
physiquement à à cette rencontre avec
les supporters et je souhaite vraiment
cette rencontre et lui le plus long vol
il a commis des fautes majeures gérald
darmanin
il a surtout parlé trop et trop vite
sans vérifier la réalité des chiffres
qu'on lui avait si oui c'est vrai que
ces messieurs l'allemand qui me l'a
donné les chiffres de 30 ou 40 mines
mais au delà la parole est ce qu'elle
est prise de décision qui lui sont
propres au châble aujourd'hui la chaîne
de commandement a échoué manifestement
il n'est pas coupable ce qui se passait
mais les responsables à lui d'en tirer
les conséquences en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que ce qui s'est passé le
28 mai au stade de france peut-être un
élément d'explication du vote parfois
très très radicales pour l'extrême
droite vous ne demandez pas sa démission
en charge homogène du je n'ai jamais
demandé de démission de personne
responsables politiques d'en tirer de
conclusion la mission du sénat se
transforme en commission denquête pour
vous elle est quasiment une commission
denquête et finalement on obtient plus
d'informations sans le serment que
qu'avec le serment donc continuons comme
ça par contre ce que nous avons demandé
ce que j'ai demandé au nom de mango
oublièrent c'est que très vite les deux
commissions soient réunies en commun
pour que nous puissions acté ensemble
les préconisations parce que le but nous
ne sommes pas des procureurs de la
république le but c'est faire des
préconisations pour que ça se reproduise
plus faux dans l'avenir une nouvelle loi
sur la gestion des supporters par
exemple il faut la conforter la loi de
2016 que j'ai porté avec thierry
braillard montre aujourd'hui n'ont pas
ces insuffisances mais ses limites et
donc il faut la conforter d'ailleurs
hier il ya eu des propositions très
intéressantes de fait merci patrick
kanner merci beaucoup d'avoir était
notre invité ce matin la une de la
dépêche christelle majorité mâcon
consulte s'étalait de votre journal
merci
[Musique]